let's see how it goes they're both great
way more beautiful than I deserve kind
of like serious naturally gonna be a
super hard decision hey my name's iffy
I'm 31 years old
occupation I'm a writer and an actor
comedian my dating status is single woo
how long I describe myself in three
words loud fun and thirsty they take
that from you know whatever you want why
am i single you know I can't ask that
you know just I guess cuz I just got out
of relationship I think my ideal
relationship as a young kid was like I
think we were all chasing like you know
relationships that we've seen on TV like
you know definitely Rogers Sister Sister
you know easy who's gone after two twins
you know he never got him but you know
what once he turned into marques houston
the game change so I'd like to imagine
I'm at the Marques Houston phase in my
life so right now I'm doing so many
things and then on top of that I have a
little daughter so I just need someone
who's easygoing and understands that I'm
gonna just be busy a lot perfect first
date I mean I definitely eaten I'd love
to eat I love trying out new spots so
definitely a nice restaurant somewhere
we can like eat chill and talk and then
like something fun to go with it so
whether it be like you know hitting up a
spot and dancing going to see a movie
Joyce is my friend so I say this would
love and I'm expecting her to set me up
on the wildest date and I don't know
what to truly expect I'm excited to see
how she shakes it up
yeah yes in the streets yeah yeah how
would you describe your love life uh you
know very chill very laid-back or
another way dry mmm I'm very excited to
see all the booty your rights get okay
so the first person I have her name is
Sonia
okay she's 29 a personal trainer mm-hm
loves hiking and stuff because you like
to work out and all that healthy stuff
yeah um loves the beach
what's this funny smart guys actually
which is you alright and then you know
loves tequila which is this she's active
she got you know you got the work outfit
you got that little thing you put on
your body when you want to so you know I
have to get my homegirl Alex trigger um
and she's fun you got some dumb videos
yeah yeah yeah you know she how big
burrito one time oh and we all know you
love a burrito hell of a thick burrito
[ __ ] can we be on our Rd Emeril tip my
co-workers been that one yet oh hey
charts having the time of their life
with this show they love me so much
my homegirl Savannah is super cool she's
in the fashion beauty in life she likes
my cooking so that's yeah it's a
ultimate bet right here you know and
she's so cute
yeah and you know she's real cool and
you know we talked a little bit while
she was on set
[Music]
[Laughter]
so next we have Alexis a Facilities
Coordinator by day and a stand-up
comedian by night I'm looking for a
partner English driven with goals but
also so let's live their life and have
fun
my deal date is something interactive
yep fun yeah she's very cute
mm-hmm you know funny only thing I know
stand-ups why because you don't need
your business being told on stage or
people subtweeting you those who are all
amazing options you know yeah you did it
yeah I killed it I'm gonna consult with
my man Zack I'll step out let y'all
handle when you get ready for some dope
days yes please
so we're gonna slide into some DMS okay
for fu so let me go yeah so tell me
about if he said okay if he's type if he
if he is a self-proclaimed bot dad he's
just kind of doing so many things so I
think if he's type would be someone who
shares his interests but is also like
independent in the sense that like he's
gonna be doing like comedy and like
shows and like streaming I like the fact
that he's already done a video with Alex
and Savannah yeah maybe there's
something there where it's almost like
okay you know them if you go on dates
with them there's like actually yeah for
like an actual like relationship both of
the two that we're gonna I mean at the
end of the day he's just looking for new
cheeks yeah here they are hi everyone my
name is Savannah Palacio I'm 23 years
old and today if you and I are on a
cooking date here at Sur lets evil I met
it be on set on our other
the video where single women pick dates
based on meals and I ended up picking a
few so this day I think is perfect for
us because it's a little bit of cooking
a little bit of talkin you know the
whole nine yards so I think I'm gonna
get a second day with it feed because I
know him and I both have the same taste
Kim and I are into kind of like eating
healthy food and so I know today's date
is kind of healthy so I think we're
gonna have fun with it are y'all bout to
head into this cooking class with
Savannah we were super hyped she was
super keen it was nice you know what she
liked my food and we about to cut some
risotto right now so you know I feel me
I can feel myself cool my we already
know what I'm doing well actually I
don't
we'll make it a real result I make
cauliflower risotto I'm sure it's
different but let's see how it goes I
see you here you like it I'm really
excited she's gonna be a good time
mm-hmm I'm thinking everything's gonna
be really yummy yeah I don't know I mean
like my cooking skills they're good you
know I'm I'm excited to see whose
cooking skills are buffered okay I'm
down for a little competition are you
ready to get started yeah let's do it
all right let's go look at that I I
think I think we did great we should
definitely open up a restaurant
Oh comment below if you would go to are
you are you mad are you
are you daddy
yeah all right says over here she's
great Matt College on day one greeting
yeah yeah she's doing a great job so if
you and I have been cooking for a while
now we haven't burned anything so I
think it's going well I'm having a good
time I don't know he's like really funny
he's very witty and super easy to talk
to so yeah we're having a great time
halfway through feeling good I'm excited
to eat who looks good I mean she has the
knife skills she got the stir skills you
know it's like I don't know it seems
like a great fit
you know she's fit fit you know she
doesn't hate the puns and that's a huge
plus you know what's the other rough as
they go
[Music]
okay so we just got done if he and I
absolutely killed it the broccoli was
awesome the risotto was even better but
the chicken we had a lot of fun I'm
super excited for our second day if
there is one I guess we'll see but for
now I gotta go eat my sorbet hey I'm
Alex and today I'm gonna be going on a
date with iffy we're going to be doing
into our skydiving at I fly I know he's
pretty athletic and likes an adventure
so I'm hoping this is a fun date it's a
wild date I'm kind of wild so I know I'm
going head to head with another girl for
this day but I'm pretty confident
because this date is fun and I think
it's gonna be pretty unique and I hope I
don't barf in the indoor skydiving thing
I mean yeah this is uh this is wild have
you ever been skydiving no not at all oh
yeah Wow okay okay I've been real
skydiving but I haven't been indoors
five okay all right you know I'll be
watching you well maybe not all right
ready yeah she's training video
keep your chin up can't wait to see how
if he looks in the thing yeah you know I
couldn't put my sick eyes at risk so you
know when now we got the champions all
right we're ready to go ready to fly I
wasn't nervous but now we have all the
home except some fairly serious business
[Music]
all right so we're halfway through the
date we just did a couple of flies this
is super fun I wasn't sure what to
expect
we're both getting the hang of it and I
think we're both having a really fun
time I definitely got the second date in
the bag all right so we got a few
flights down I'm having a blast this is
so much fun I mean I'm I don't know I
think I look weird the whole time so I
don't know if she's even gonna want
another day truly gonna be a super hard
decision to make they're both great
amazing both way more beautiful than I
deserve let's get back on this date it's
a lot just because you don't have to
jump out of a plane
okay it's really fun like the feeling of
flying like that in the wind but like
it's hard to look cute what was the
hardest part I think it would like keep
in mind trying to remember it's like
like straight up chin up and then you
like kind of are going all over but when
it was really fun we - he took us up
high yeah yeah I was like oh so I'm back
from my date with if he I thought we
both had a really fun time I have to say
for a first date
indoor skydiving was a little bit of a
risky choice just because one you don't
get to talk to each other too much and
two you definitely look a little bit
crazy
it was super fun it's super memorable
and definitely a little wild and crazy
like I am so we'll see who gets the next
stage oh man they were dope they're so
fun tell me what you do at Savannah well
we went to sur La Table we learned how
to you know chef a little bit we don't
have had a little song something that's
a chicken all the stuff it was great I'm
like found out that you know sheshe
games too she streams on Twitch as well
okay tell me about Alex
Oh Alex about that day was super fun so
she took me skydiving because you know
she she said I look like someone who
likes that bencher and she was
completely right - you went indoor
skydiving right there on the city walk
it was very loud we didn't really get a
chance to talk that much but it was real
pool doing tricks and having this man
throw us around we loved being thrown
around Batman but yeah like when we did
get a chance to talk I love the energy I
love just a bubbly fun she was and
that's kind of what I'm looking for a
person someone outgoing like you so it
was like it we definitely vibed but we
didn't get a chance to really see how
deep that line goes okay so I'm gonna
ask you the big question would you go
for the girl who took you out on the
food day you guys made a delicious meal
and like a really a great relationship
like some food and loves your cooking or
do you go for the fun adventurous girl
who it's really great also with food and
does really cool things I mean I yeah
it's really our choice who we gonna jizz
I think in the end I think it's gonna be
Savannah Wow why don't you pick Savannah
just the just way my like life works
right now so someone who seems like
they're down and just like stay in right
now and and kind of you know get their
game on they'll understand all the weird
things I'm doing you don't have that
wait night show with twitch now yeah you
know someone who understands the
platform actually goes a long way the
boo has been built the villa has I've
done my job
the building is I've done my to build a
boo enjoys
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]